-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-nominated actor
who stars on "This Is Us,"
which airs Tuesdays at
9:00 p.m. on NBC.
Everyone please welcome
Milo Ventimiglia!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on!
That's my man right there.
-What's going on?
What's going on?
-It's so great
to see you, buddy.
Happy, happy New Year to you.
-Happy New Year to you, as well.
Sorry I'm not around.
I was hoping to be
in New York with you,
but production and protocols
and all that, so...
-Next time.
Congrats on the premiere.
A good man.
I want to talk to you about
a couple things.
You know I follow you
on Instagram,
and it's a
very interesting follow.
It's a good follow.
I like it because --
-Because it's nothing.
-Yes, that's correct.
It is nothing,
and then it's something.
It's like, all of a sudden --
You post like every couple
months or a month or so.
You'll post like
100 photos at once.
-Yeah. Like, I've realized
sometimes, it's kind of like,
"Wow, I really haven't been
on in a while,
and I've been living life
and I've been hiking
and I've been seeing
people and friends
and family and all that."
And I kind of have
this collection of photos
in a folder on my phone
that I've just kind of,
you know,
taken over a period of time,
like six months,
and then I'm like,
"Alright, let me
just put up 100.
Why not?"
-Yeah, they really are.
They're like --
Yeah, 100 photos.
And you just look through them,
and everyone's like,
"Oh, my gosh."
And then they go everywhere.
And they're --
Some are beautiful.
Some are just cool.
Some --
-Some are ridiculous.
-Yes.
-Like, I've had some --
Like, there was one -- It was --
I took a photo of my couch
in my trailer.
And just the way the light
was hitting it
and the lines,
and it kind of lined up.
And people were like,
"Is this a couch that is
on your Instagram now?
Are we supposed to like that?"
-Yeah.
Pictures of couches. Why not?
-Yeah, sure, why not?
-I started getting my
photos printed out
because I miss
holding the photos
and putting them in albums
and looking at them
and having people go,
"Oh, yeah,"
and all these, man, 'cause
everything is just on my phone.
I'm going to get a photo that
you posted printed out, too.
Is this a picture of your --
Is this just your gym shorts
or what are these?
-Yeah. Those are my shorts.
Ride 'em high, kids.
-Yeah, ride 'em high, kids.
I think -- It made me laugh when
you said "Ride 'em high,"
because it came from some
paparazzi photo I saw of you,
I guess, leaving the gym?
Is that what it was?
-I was leaving the gym,
funny enough,
post-appearing on your show.
-Is that right?
You appeared on our show,
and it got you pumped up,
ready to go work out?
-I was so excited.
I was so charged up.
It was like "Scarface."
I was ready to go.
I had the best leg day
of my life, and there it is.
-Yeah, and, so, you work out
and you have a good workout,
and then you come out,
and "Ride 'em high, kids."
This is what's in the --
-Ride 'em high, kids.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah!
-Oh, man.
That was so much --
I really had no idea.
So, when I work out, you know,
I'm with my trainer,
Jason Walsh,
and we're just, you know,
kind of meatheads
throwing around a lot of weight.
And when I work out,
I kind of pull my shorts up.
-Yeah.
-And so then,
when I left the gym
and the photograph got taken,
and then it went bananas --
-It really did.
-It went crazy. Literally crazy.
Like broke-the-Internet crazy.
And I was -- They were like,
"Oh, my God.
Milo wears short shorts.
It's the summer of
short shorts."
There's "New York Times"
articles.
There's "GQ" articles.
There's all these articles about
Milo and his short shorts.
Yeah, seriously.
And I'm just like,
"Guys, they were actually
really normal length.
I just have,
like, kind of meaty thighs,
and I pulled them up and I
walked out and they stuck."
-Yeah. You yanked them up, man.
You've got some
muscular legs there.
You had a good workout.
It was a leg day, I guess.
-Yeah.
-Every day is a good leg day.
-Not only is "This Is Us" back,
but next month,
we're going to see you
in the new season of
"The Marvelous Mrs. Maisel."
-Yes, you are.
-That is -- Reunited.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Reunited with
Amy Sherman-Palladino.
-Yeah. It's, you know,
back in -- It's amazing.
I mean, you know, Amy and
Dan Palladino, her husband,
who also is an incredibly
accomplished writer, you know,
they really gave me my break.
Like, they were the ones that
kind of put me on the map
with "Gilmore" and with Jess,
your favorite, I know.
And they are the kinds of
people that, for me,
I was like, "I'm, one, going to
know them the rest of my life,
and, two, anytime they call,
I've got to be there."
So if they're like, "Hey, Mi,
why don't you come in
and do a small bit on a show
we're working on..."
"Great."
"Hey, if you could take us
to the airport..."
"Sure."
-That's why you're here.
You're there for each other.
-Yeah, absolutely.
-They know how
to write, too, huh?
-My God, I mean,
it's one of those things
where you don't really think
about the script
because you just trust and
you know it's going to be great.
It's going to be golden.
And, also, I mean, back in the
days of "Gilmore," I mean,
we had these
massive, massive scripts,
and that, for me,
felt like a proving ground
as an actor to really
soak in the words,
really understand
the poetry of it,
and then deliver it,
you know, put what I can on it
to make it come out naturally,
because, you know, the way
they write is definitely prose.
It's incredible.
-I want to talk about
"This Is Us."
This is the sixth --
This is the final season.
Premiered tonight.
-Yes, it is.
-And you're filming
the final season now.
And, of course,
everyone's going to ask you,
and I probably know the answer,
but do you know how it ends
or do you know --
or are there still secrets
that you don't know?
Because the show is
always twists and turns,
and right before it's the --
Two minutes before
the end of the show you're like,
"Oh, I get this."
And then you're like, "What?!"
-Yeah, yeah. That's how it goes.
-And you're crying.
-I mean, listen, Fogelman --
Dan Fogelman is
incredibly candid with us
about his intentions with
the show, with the characters.
So he kind of ran us through
what he was doing at the end.
So I think I have a
pretty good idea
of what's going to happen,
what's to come.
But, also -- So, right now,
myself, Mandy, and Justin
are all directing a trilogy.
And we were all on set
right before the break,
and Dan was around and he was
talking about his work
on the last two episodes.
And, you know,
your heart rate starts going
and the excitement to know
what he's working on.
It's like, "Oh,
this is going to be great."
It's going to absolutely
probably crush people
in the best possible way,
because that's Fogelman's goal
is to make people feel
something in life.
-Yeah, you start
rolling up your shorts.
-Yeah,
I start rolling up my shorts.
-Rolling up the shorts, getting
ready for the thing, yeah.
-I'm ready. Yeah, yeah.
Call Jimmy.
I've got to interview
and do some legs.
-I got to see the first episode,
and you're phenomenal in it.
And I want to show a clip here.
But I thought it was charming,
because it's you
singing to Mandy Moore.
And I just think --
I just know you a little bit,
but I know you, and that's got
to be pressure singing
to Mandy Moore,
who's a professional singer.
-Yes. A professional singer
whose husband is
a professional musician.
-That's correct, yeah.
-And I have no pipes at all.
I'm not musically inclined.
But, yet, they are like, "Hey,
we wrote this really sweet scene
where you're singing
REO Speedwagon to your TV wife."
And I'm like, "Great.
Here we go."
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
-That's love.
-That is love.
But you were saying something
when you were on the show before
that when you started working
with Mandy, you kind of made,
like, a pact with each other.
You just said, "Hey..."
-Yeah. We did. We did.
Right before the show premiered,
we were in New York
for the up-fronts,
the big advertiser conference,
and everybody
was kind of milling about.
Mandy and I were just, like,
off to the side by ourselves,
and we just kind of raised
our glasses to one another.
We almost took vows with
one another, where it was like,
"Hey, I promise
to always communicate.
I promise to not be happy
until you're happy.
I will always look out for you."
And all that.
And we have stayed very true to
what we said in the beginning.
I mean, I've got to say,
she has been probably,
in my 26 years
in front of the camera,
the best partner I've ever had.
Her commitment, her dedication,
her growth as an artist.
Like, you know, the audience --
you guys all get to watch
the show in its entirety.
I get to sit there in front of
her or stand in front of her
or lay in a bed next to her
and watch, front row,
what she does
and how impactful it is,
the work is to her,
and I've only seen it grow.
So it's been a pleasure to be
her TV husband for six years,
and, at the same time,
closing this chapter,
I'm very excited to see
what Mandy does next,
because she's such a force.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Milo Ventimiglia in the
new season of "This Is Us."
Take a look at this.
-REO Speedwagon are
the new Beatles.
You remember I said that.
-[ Laughs ]
-♪ What started out as
friendship has grown stronger ♪
♪ I only wish I had
the strength to let it show ♪
-Oh, you're letting it show.
-I am?
-Mm-hmm.
-Okay, break it up, people.
-Big day.
-I know. Hey, guys.
See what I have for you
in honor of today?
Tang.
-Tang!
-Hold on, hold on, hold on.
-Whoa! Slow down. Slow down.
Okay, now, dad's off.
So goodbye kiss, kiss, kiss.
I want all the details later.
Um...briefcase?
-In the living room.
-What would I do without you?
-Yeah. REO Speedwagon.
-What would I do with her?
-REO Speedwagon
is the new Beatles.
-Yeah!
-Milo Ventimiglia, everybody.
"This Is Us" airs Tuesdays
at 9:00 p.m. on NBC.